[Music]
the business that takes care of people
from spa treatments to massages took a
big hit during covid but after a
two-year pause i spa is back this is
actually a three-day convention it's all
about the spa
products services christian casadas
joins us now live in studio tonight with
more on how the industry though is uh
set for a really big rebound yeah that's
right guys this is great news here
because this is the industry that is
once again growing according to folks at
ispah now they say the pandemic proved
spa services aren't a luxury but rather
a necessity for our health
you need to take care of yourself to
function as a human being liz freeman
with sorel apothecary is thrilled to be
back in person at i spa after a two-year
pause she says the reno based company
like so many others had to be innovative
to survive we had to think of you know
what are people looking for during this
time when they're not able to be in the
treatment room or in their space
with their clients so we did a lot of
virtual training others like this
apparel company still facing challenges
to meet demands logistics and supply
chain has been impacted certainly it's
impacted us
but we were closer with our clients
while many companies shut down freeman
says they expanded their product line a
similar story for many businesses
pushing for better skin care and less
physical touch a lot of people are still
concerned about the having treatments
being in contact with the practitioner
this year more than 260 companies are at
the convention at the mandalay bay
patrick hughey with the international
spa association says this industry is
still crucial to the consumer in las
vegas it's not unusual to see people
coming in who have not been touched by
another human being for a year or two
years because they live in large cities
and that when they come into the spa
they break down they cry huey says the
pandemic also helped the industry come
together sharing information staff and
concerns a support system this nevada
company says is proud to be a part of a
lot of people could have you know said
oh well this isn't necessary but i mean
giving yourself that self-care i feel
like is the base of just everything that
you do every day
all right so a layout of health and
safety procedures is a major feature
that has changed in the industry
according to i spa now those details
were held before to offer more of a
seamless experience overall they say a
spa is not a luxury anymore but more of
a necessity so there you go guys
christian gaza is live local now